ja unser Bundeswirtschaftsminister
Robert Habeck hat eine riesen
Ausschreibung gerade laufen sein
Ministerium sein Haus er will Juristen
verpflichten juristische Berater über
also als externe Dienstleister für bis
zu 20 Millionen Euro für die kommenden
Jahre für Beratungsleistungen in der
Energiekrise und er sagt dazu das müsste
jetzt sein weil die Leute in seinem
Ministerium überarbeitet sein aber es
sind 2400 Mitarbeiter die er hat
natürlich zuständig für unterschiedliche
Bereiche das ist auch klar aber es ist
so es sind genau diese Mitarbeiter es
sind diese Beamten die dafür zuständig
sind ähm Verordnung auszuarbeiten
Gesetze sind Würfe auszuarbeiten und so
weiter es ist ein Unding es ist ein
verpulver von Steuergeldern das
Ministerien wie seines immer nach
externer Beratung rufen und für solche
Millionenbeträge da jetzt ähm
Unterstützung haben wollen das kann
nicht sein wir Bürger müssen ständig den
Gürtel engerstein an jeder Stelle der
Staat sollte das auch tun und kann nicht
20 Millionen für sowas verbunden sein
sage ich also 20 drinstehende Auslaufen
ist das ein reizvoller Job sie sind vom
Fach sozusagen aber was ist denn da für
so eine Berater Stunde was berechnet man
denn da so das ist ja man muss dazu
sagen das ist ja nichts Neues der der
Staat lässt sich ja im Gerichtsverfahren
schon lange von einer Handvoll größerer
Kanzleien vertreten die Namen sind auch
bekannt wer das ist und dass man da für
eine was er sich für eine partnerstunde
oder wer das macht 350 € die Stunde
bezahlt Minimum das ist auch kein
Geheimnis das ist mussten sie ja
irgendwann auf auf klagen genau
aufdecken weil ja freiwillig machen die
das ja nicht was ist denn ihr
Stundensatz eigentlich ähm es kommt also
für den Start würde ich wahrscheinlich
genauso viel abrufen sagen was man so
also das ist selbst für für
Rechtsanwälte die die Stundensätze
abbrechenden deutlich
überdurchschnittliches honora der
Durchschnitt liegt bei 200 20 25 Euro im
Bundesdurchschnitt wenn man nach einer
Stunde abrechnet und nicht nach dem
Rechtsanwaltsvergütungsgesetz von daher
das ist erstmal nichts Neues die
Dimension die das annimmt und die
Offensivität mit der das gemacht wird
wo kommt auf einmal diese Überarbeitung
her und der Personalmangel bei 2400
Mitarbeitern das ist die Frage die ich
mir stelle und ich sehe da natürlich
auch wenn wenn wir schon mit
Rechtsstaatlichkeit um die Ecke kommen
es ist ein ganz massives
rechtsstaatlichkeitsproblem wenn Gesetze
Gesetzesentwürfe und solche Sachen de
facto von privaten ausgearbeitet werden
von denen wir nicht wissen von wem sie
ihr Geld sonst noch bekommen das ist
auch eine ganz einfache Rechnung wenn
man so eine große Wirtschaftskanzlei
anheuert und man soll zu
energiewirtschaftlichen Themen ein
Gesetzesentwurf ausarbeiten und die
haben einer von deren Mandanten ist zum
Beispiel weiß ich ja nicht aber kann ja
sein ein großes
energiewirtschaftsunternehmen die werden
nichts unternehmen was zu diesem
Unternehmen Schaden zufügen wird 200 400
Mitarbeiter hat er das
Wirtschaftsministerium und jetzt ist es
Argument ja man bräuchte auch mehr
Spezialisten der wird sich natürlich die
Frage auf geht's unter den 2400
Mitarbeiter nicht genug Spezialisten
glauben Sie das sind tatsächlich so
spezielle Fragen und Fällen Fälle dass
man da unter den 2400 nicht eigene
Spezialisten hat also ich hatte das für
insofern unwahrscheinlich weil die Leute
sitzen da ja erstens direkt an der
Quelle
und man muss natürlich auch sagen wenn
da keine Spezialisten sitzen warum
werden dann keine Spezialisten
eingestellten man kann natürlich sagen
die Leute die die Spezialisten sind und
was auf dem Kasten haben die gehen nicht
und arbeiten im Ministerium bei Ihnen
das Gehalt zu gering ist also von daher
da kommen wir zu vom hunderten ins
Tausendste von der von die was die
Problemlage angeht und das ist generell
muss man sagen für den Staat im ein
Problem geworden qualifizierte Juristen
in den Staatsdienst zu holen weil die
dort schlicht und ergreifen erstens
nicht mehr genug Geld verdienen und
zweitens die Arbeitsbelastung z.B auch
bei Richtern und Staatsanwältin
astronomisch geworden ist und man ähm
Technik stand auch Deutschland keine
Unterstützung bekommen
in meinem Team die können nicht mehr die
müssen auch mal schlafen die müssen auch
mal essen die haben Tinnitus die kriegen
Burnout da ist er doch eigentlich ein
toller Chef wenn er sagt so jetzt
brauche ich halt neue Leute und die
Kosten eben auch was und die muss ich
jetzt einstellen also vielleicht mal auf
politischer Ebene kann ich aus
Österreich ein bisschen erzählen dass
die Erfahrung lehrt das ist gar nicht so
schlimm ist in Deutschland ja also wir
haben es glaube ich ein bisschen mehr
noch verbockt was politikskandale an und
so weiter angeht also da vielleicht
vielleicht ein bisschen Beruhigung
reinbringen von der österreichischen
Seite und natürlich die die Frage also
Burnout das ist ja momentan Begriff der
große Runden macht ja weil die Leute
natürlich massiv überarbeitet worden
sind weil sie meines Erachtens auch in
Berufen arbeiten die für diese
klassischen acht Stunden am Tag absitzen
gar nicht gebaut sind ja also geistige
Berufe wie ist der Anwalt z.B auch ist
eine ganze Menge verschiedene Anweisung
Berufe da drin die im politischen Sektor
sehr oft unterwegs sind die sinnvoll
solche durchgehenden Arbeitsbelastung
einfach nicht gebaut also ich glaube da
würde man vielleicht allen das ist ja
auch mein großes Thema
morgen kommen wir noch zu vielleicht ein
bisschen mehr auf Flexibilität ich weiß
Flexibilität im Start das klingt schon
quasi unmöglich weil mein
arbeitskonzepten wäre vielleicht
empfehlenswert dann brennt einem
vielleicht nicht alle sofort raus jetzt
im Herbst 100 neue Leute eingestellt
also hat er schon entgegengewirkt und
jetzt wieder wie wird das Aufsehen ja es
ist ein Krebsgeschwür seit Jahren die
Staatsquote ist schon bei über 50% was
immer ein Zeichen dafür ist das was
nicht ganz in Ordnung ist das ist
Richtung Sozialismus geht und wir sehen
ja wie der Staat immer mehr Menschen
eigentlich de facto einstellt immer mehr
Personal braucht also wir haben ja in
der Führungsriege das hat die letzten
Jahre haben es auch gewesen eine Art ähm
Fachkräftemangel ne und jetzt sehen wir
halt einfach dass der ähm startet der
größte Arbeitgeber ist und es sind ja
Sachen die wir bezahlen müssen und warum
muss ich dann immer noch zwischen meinen
eigenen Führerschein bezahlen Steuern
drin sind die Steuerquote ist schon die
höchste weltweit die wir bezahlen immer
neue Abgaben das heißt wenn der Stadt
immer weiter mutiert immer mehr
Mitarbeiter einstellt die Menschen immer
mehr abhängig werden auch vom Staat
werden die andere Wahl oder natürlich
nicht immer das gleiche Ergebnis
erzielen und natürlich auch abhängiges
entsteht eine Abhängigkeit eine
ungesunde Abhängigkeit weil ich bin mir
sicher die drei vier fünf Millionen
Staatsangestellten die werden definitiv
kein Wandel initiieren und das ist wie
ich finde brandgefährlich für uns und
Demokratie dass wir immer mehr Menschen
in der Abhängigkeit vom Staat haben
immer mehr heißt doch nicht immer besser
muss man sagen man kann auch noch 500
Leute mehr anstellen wenn die
Arbeitskonzepte einfach mal Rode sind
und die Produktivität nicht stimmt und
das ist was mich immer interessiert
immer mehr Produktivität raus dann kann
man noch 10.000 Leute anstellen und
besser als nichts geworden also ich
glaube da muss man mit neuen
arbeitskonzepten auch an diese doch
manchmal alten verkrusteten Strukturen
ran dann braucht man vielleicht nicht so
viele Leute die dann insgesamt
produktiver sind es gibt ja dann noch
die Abhilfe der Digitalisierung eines
Tages irgendwann mal auch in Deutschland
ich hoffe dass die künstliche
Intelligenz irgendwann von der Politik
entdeckt wird und sagt kommt die können
uns zur Seite stellen oder vielleicht
sogar die Politiker setzen ich hatte
ehrlich gesagt lieber wenn die Politik
erstmal die natürliche intelligente
an der Algorithmen aber man merkt schon
dass der Berufsstand natürlich jetzt
jetzt einmal durch die Neuerungen der
künstlichen Intelligenz auch zum ersten
Mal bedroht ist also die
hochsegmentberuf wenn man so die sehr
gut bezahlten Berufe wie Werbetexter
Journalisten zum Beispiel auch ja das
ist auf einmal die Berufe das sind auch
immer die Berufe die bedroht sind also
der Zukunft sicherste Job momentan ist
Krankenpflegerin oder
tagesschwester für Kinder das ist
momentan der sicherste Job den man
nehmen kann verschlafen bisschen
verstaubt die falschen Strukturen du
berichtest seit Jahren auch bis dann
auch tief drinnen mit deinen Kontakten
Innenministerium wie verschlafen ist die
Arbeitswelt dort also wird es
weitergehen wenn wir das Zukunftsmodell
zeichnen das immer mehr Leute immer mehr
Personal aber man ändert an den
Strukturen nichts und dann hilft es auch
überhaupt nicht also diese sind ja schon
sehr gut abgesichert natürlich kann man
in der freien Wirtschaft erstmal mehr
verdienen aber Leute die haben gute
Beamten stellen die kassieren am Ende
eine Pension die wirklich sehr gut ist
das gibt's in der freien Wirtschaft so
nicht da muss man klar sagen und ich
kaufe ehrlicherweise das mit der
Überlastung nicht so ganz ab natürlich
sind die in der Energiekrise jetzt
besonders gefordert das zuständige
Referat dann alles andere wäre auch
völlig überraschen aber jetzt zu sagen
oh die müssen jetzt Überstunden machen
ja natürlich wenn wir Bundestagswahl
haben meine Kollegen und ich in Politik
Resort dann machen wir auch Überstunden
das gehört eben mit dazu dann ist man
eben gefordert so ein Minister wie ein
Corona natürlich musste er besonders ran
wir müssen die zuständig Leute besonders
ran äh das ist sicherlich so es ist aber
auch ein abschieben von Verantwortung
weil man nämlich dann eben sagt ah das
hat uns jetzt mit Kinsey oder irgendwer
irgendwelche tollen Wirtschaftsberater
haben uns dazu das geraten und die
bringen ganz tolle flexible Modelle sind
mit und deswegen wenn die das so sagen
dann machen wir das jetzt so ne weil man
selbst sich offensichtlich teilweise
auch nicht traut dann die Entscheidung
zu treffen auch das spielt er nämlich
immer eine Rolle und deswegen sollte
glaube ich dieses ganze Beratungswesen
da insgesamt zurückgefahren werden in
den Ministerium bei Verantwortung
abgeschoben